we come together can I get some examples
of people and the amount choices that
you make we start with you - okay food
choices thank you okay
what am I gonna eat another daily one
clothing what do I wear okay Ricky okay
sleepy okay okay time for sleeping good
sleep time good sleep time so we give
you one more a daily decision Hayley
yeah okay uh toothpaste flavor sure why
not okay I'm very boring I only even
have one flavor of toothpaste open at a
time so this is like a little not a
choice I have to me but you know I
suppose if you're actually I remember
when I was going on I suppose anything
we used to have we used to routinely
have like eight or nine different boxes
of cereal always open at a time and it
drove my mom nuts she's like why did
just eat material and then finish it and
then go into the next like so anyway I
mean yeah maybe you're like that with
toothpaste who knows okay there are some
daily decisions good thanks
how about decisions you make on a week
to week basis right what what kinds of
choices do you have thoughts
okay okay so so the location of your
shopping like grocery shopping I take it
that's something we don't do well most
of us don't do every single day very
inefficient okay so that's a good one
yeah ah okay good so um the items that
you get so this is about location and
about what you actually purchase okay
can we have another one on a weekly
basis Connie did you think it one week
basis making weekly one's a bit trickier
anyone else when I go you've got one Oh
Howard that's not a choice that's okay
tonight should I wake up and drag myself
today in class okay any others things
you know do so frequently so therefore
there may be a little more important
yeah yeah I don't know if I should put
that down this is okay so attendance
yeah no I'm gonna leave that one off
okay maybe that's not weekly that's
anyway okay so there's this and choices
you have to make let's think on a larger
timescales okay
so what's something they only do once a
year once a year yeah that many things I
suppose all kinds of choices do you have
to me what's oh good gifts I I am really
bad with gifts I hate that we had this
annual cycle on which you have to get
people like I'm not against gifts
themselves but like the fact that you
know rolls around the Christmas feel
like I am horribly obliged to to get
your gift even though you don't need
anything you don't want to get anywhere
okay that's a good one right another one
I know what else do we do for meeting
here
okay yeah yes so these are sort of minor
things that yeah i can'twe that you
should do april fools or christmas and
reason and that kind of thing so these
are things which turn on it on the
calendar right yeah good medical
check-ups that's a good one now um let's
go on that a little more what kind of
decisions would you have to make about a
medical checkup
yeah good see all these different ones
whether you should go to them or not of
who you should go to where you should
get a second opinion so on yeah one more
okay so yeah all right again like these
are do these choices you guys get toward
their voluntary right now let's have a
think you have the really fun one what a
lot of things that you only have to
choose once ever probably maybe twice
yeah okay they are cuz dr. Ahluwalia
I really two oceans right okay Korea
Korea that's a good that's a good one
give me some other ones give you some
other ones what other kinds of choices
do we make yeah yeah say yeah ah okay
marital status maybe actually it's kind
of funny like just when you think about
it now it's a bit of a skewed image but
more or less all of you even the
weirdest people of you will probably get
married because the way people find each
other anyway Saburo says so here you're
gonna whether you should marry who
you're gonna marry when you're gonna
marry that's actually a big ones I think
so like who who or whether yep retire
what about retirement
okay so again job job sort of related
things okay retirement you could say
should I go for promotion right maybe
hope that's not a once in the last time
think maybe you're here that's gonna
happen to you Muslim types okay
perhaps where you live right where are
you going to set up your home okay I
along the lines of career just pedaling
back a few years before that where are
you going to go just study right or what
will you study okay will you go to
Sydney on you South okay or those kinds
of decisions okay
Oh Mac what a sure and you all the other
multiple good options they're all fine
I'm not biased in any way signals the
Fisk University
anyway there we go okay so there there's
a whole set of decisions okay now what I
want to get at it is particularly as you
go sort of up the scale or larger in
time right just even just as individuals
right these decisions get harder and
harder to make like well maybe you think
this is a really hard like what's yours
I kissed you when I'm a plague on you
can I see people to can team they're
like it's life or death whether I get a
sausage roll or sushi but anyway as you
go further along right these decisions
have higher stakes and you want to make
good decisions right and when you think
this is all mostly individual basis
track because you're all thinking about
yourselves as individuals what if you're
an organization like a government or a
company or a hospital or a school all
those kinds of things all these
decisions suddenly increase in scale
because they matter they affect other
people right yeah yeah exactly like
there's a whole what you think I say
government right there are all these
different kinds of decisions which we
don't even have to worry about generally
okay
which a lot of time and effort and money
goes into making those choices so that
leads us into what we're actually
covering today this is the your last
topic for this HSE course
okay and the the name of the topic is
decision support systems
okay decision support systems now this
is one of the cases where the people who
make up names have done your favor and
decision support systems sounds like
exactly what it is what do you think it
sounds like it's a system that supports
helps facilitate provides guidance in
you making decisions okay so there's my
start of definition let me get that down
okay a DSS okay it's a system and it
supports your decision-making process
okay it supports your decision-making
process so I have two T now that's
really important that do we say it's a
supporting because the idea is not that
it replaces you generally speaking right
it's about providing extra help it's
it's still humans making decisions
really okay so even though we'll look at
some systems on shortly which seem
completely autonomous okay hiddens are
still the ones calling the shots okay
we're still not really I mean we're
we're gonna talk about artificial
intelligence as we progress through this
topic right but we still have humans by
and large calling the shots and turning
things on and off and making decisions
about whether they should agree with a
DSS or not okay so this is what decision
support system basically ears and when
you think about it you actually use
decision support systems all the time
okay let's think about really really low
tech ones right because we we like to
think about manual stuff before you
military stuff what he eat when you eat
how do you make that decision how do you
choose what kinds of information and
data do you use to make that decision
yeah okay so what time is it so you know
you have to think about is a breakfast
is a lunch crunch whatever okay yeah
yeah okay so you get Google nose beta
out or whatever might you smell it okay
you're all this information passing in
to you in terms of like concrete details
and stuff though if you're like maybe
maybe you guys cuz you're young don't
worry about it that much but we think
about nutrition right and we have
systems sorry we think some people out
there maybe not you think about
nutrition okay tiny calories whatever
okay and so we have decision support
systems designed to help people make
choices about what they should eat based
on what nutrition it has it right
so we already use systems like this on a
very sort of word mundane scale okay